I can't believe this this is gonna blow
your mind
wow dude
dollar store glasses my mind is blown
you don't get it try them on so this is
what you came to clothe about virtual
reality glasses not virtual reality
where'd you get those at the dollar
store now we see what these bad boys can
do oh they must have been in creative
mode Yeah right don't look at me don't
ever one good me yeah tell weird it felt
weird go two blocks all the blocks what
wait
hang on oh wait a minute wait a minute
dude I have an idea come on give me
those I have the best idea I don't have
the armor
[Music]
I need you to make this disappear thanks
so much for watching if you enjoyed this
video and want to see more than please
check out Matthias his channel he did
pretty much everything on this video and
he's got a special alternate ending to
this video over there just click on his
lovely face a lot of work was put into
this so please share with your friends
and do whatever you can to spread the
word thanks again everyone and I will
see you in the next video bye bye